walk him to this video game 10 coverage
of the World Championship match between
Russia anandan Magnus Carlsen yeah y'all
know that Carlton's want game 9 and
young therefore took a very convincingly
door six points 23 points and you need
six and a half points to win the match
so this means out of the remaining three
games some Anand would need three
consecutive wins to draw the match and
make it make it at 66 to the tie breaks
so it's basically an a lost cause but
the game sir or at least this game needs
to be played at council needs this one
draw to to get the child home so let's
see him what do what happened yeah money
for this was to be expected if you want
to play it safe on that level e for some
usually the good good choice and the
vishie is going for the Sicilian
probably am aiming for night off and ER
Carlton is not going into that just
playing Bishop b5 check the so-called
Moscow variegation yet here either she
has played both Bishop d7 and 97 in this
game he played 97 and in fact this he
had played only only recently this year
in this novagen super tournament I'm not
quite sure norway masters not quite sure
about the exact name but this tournament
was played in various cities in Norway
they played this carlton against island
then turn tells it a very nice position
we will see him what what happened in
this game briefly played now deform this
is some the most ambitious way to play
against 97
you get your queen out early and this is
an idea because okay the natural 96 it's
obviously not possible anymore so the
queen is nicely placed in the middle of
the board yeah I don't know a six and
the capture this is one benefit of 97
you very often get the bishop s white
does not really want to retreat the
bishop from be five but exchanges on
this heaven so that black has got those
two bishops which is nice on the other
hand and why it has a very good lead in
development and with the c4 he also said
sets up dumb blonde known maroc see bind
where this pawns on c4 and deform um
young established very nice central
control uh not not played Knight f6 and
this is new for for his or in a
practical game that is playing in this
mansion tournament in Norway he had
played 'if I've against cards and really
got into some trouble I mean this is
continued Queen B 3 and B 593 takes
takes and at the end Carlton this is a
probably okay for black but at the end
cars managed to to get something this
two against one potential a spawn and he
also made good use of the weekend Queen
side so when an i didn't wanted to
repeat this type of position and played
9006 ya hear the meaning of this
actually Knight c3 but cousin played
Bishop g5 which certainly makes sense
what prevents any ideas that black might
have to play g6 because okay this is a
disaster the phone structures completely
wrecked so blankets basically forced to
play e6 and now all this is very logical
indeed I'm instead of castling in fact
there has been played rock d one before
all and I only quote this because this
is a very recent game played in
September only two month ago in an event
in Paris and the white player is no half
crazy named one of the top French
players and this is interesting because
we're the knee is believed to be in
Magnus's team so he's worked with him
before but I'm not sure if he's in this
exact teen na for the World Championship
match though there might be some
connection down and therefore Anand
maybe could have expected this type of
opening he could have expected Bishop b5
and so on anyway because Magnus has
played this numerous times before so
castles Bishop to c6 yeah makes sense
get some pressure against you for and
now queen bee three this is an important
move Queen d3 it fulfills a double
function it removes the Queen from
possible attacks on d4 and it also
allows white to play Knight d4 and maybe
just get rid of this Bishop to make sure
that black does not keep the the bishop
pair for a long time after castles 94
exactly that happened b3 first plate and
now white get rid of this night on at
this is a bishop on c6 to make sure that
the bishop pass is gone yeah how to
assess this position this is a fairly
typical structure the maraki bind pawns
against the small center this is similar
to to the Hedgehog structure which
includes be 6v6 is not played here which
is a slight difference but not not a
decisive one and one important point
here is that white does not have a light
squared Bishop anymore which very often
is positioned on e 2 or GTFO fianchetto
has been played and this Bishop
sometimes
out to be not to be such a great piece
because those pawns are all on light
squares but okay this is not the major
major issue um in general black only has
got to active plants when the boys got
b5 and he's got d5 those two porn breaks
and whites play is basically centered
around preventing those two breaks if
black is not allowed to do play any of
those palm breaks and white in the
meantime does increase his some control
over the position and white um retains
some edge and we see in the game that
exactly this is happening it's not like
black is in big trouble but it's like
it's a very comfortable position a thing
for white you can play without any risk
all this seems very normal little
strengthening moves to know aren't
intended to activate the Queen it's not
doing much on sistex anyway so this is
basically the type of position that
pretty much sums up this this entire
match Carlton is looking for positions
where there is not particularly much
going on but also for positions that he
is absolutely zero risk in and where you
can try around a bit and play do the
slow Trixie and then sort of built up
pressure like deceptively and you don't
really see where it is coming and at one
point he really has something and this
is also an example of this if we look at
this all very normal looking moves Queen
d2 for example is a little move that has
some idea whenever you have this kind of
situation those two queens are looking
at each other there's a knight on c3
there's always this nice d5 at the end
that black needs to be well let's say
four
for example um black plays nothing move
here let's say op8 it doesn't make much
sense I know but I want to demonstrate
the idea that 95 is still big Adam when
the queen is hanging and the bishop is
hanging and after Queen d2 note that
this is not a check this is important if
the king is on you want that's a
different story but now why can't take
only seven with a check this is
important this is uncovered this Bishop
unprotected and in this case wide wins
this important porn on g7 and basically
wins the game 95 is a motif that you
always need to have in mind so Queen d2
a sort of sort of threatening 95 and are
not reacted with King evade yeah just
making sure that only seven there's no
check so after 95 now Queen d2 you
cannot take on his hand with the check
so this move has says some sense it's
not just a waiting move ok King evade
King be two and a queen bee to sorry
sort of building up on g7 and yeah it's
not it's not maybe a real threat here
but Anna just went back why not and in
this position actually a council
could've played Queen d2 to ask out ok
what are you doing now to play king of
eight again to make a draw or are you
trying to really win three games in a
row but it didn't do that he just played
a form and therefore also signaling ok
I'm not going for a draw anyway so let's
just let's just play and the a4 is a
good move to control b5 note that black
is ages away from playing d5 or b-five
here you could justin is in a sit-in
wait situation and somewhere around here
we have some more peace trades and queen
522 and now Knight f6 somewhere around
here I think under this drifting into
into slight difficulties but I'm not one
hundred percent sure where to pinpoint
the exact situation where you should
improve of course d 6 is a slight issue
in this position but it doesn't seem
like the end of the world maybe I could
have played them better before at least
after Knight f6 it gets somewhat tricky
and the computer wants to play Knight c5
and claims that after rookie three
coming f6 37 the position is around
equal I don't really buy that I think
white is still somewhat more comfortable
but this is some better than the game
because there are some ideas here that
that are quite cute let's say five
Queenie seven quite quite normal and if
now white tries to play a direct
approach with B form like has got this
interesting movie 5 rook d5 and 96 this
is a very interesting that the night on
c5 might actually drop back to e6 so I'm
quite interesting concept I'm still
white if he is patient and cars neser
basically the most patient play around
and what still I keep something I'm also
little bit biased to be honest I always
enjoyed the Roxy bind positions with e
for c4 and especially here with some
pieces traded there's very little
counter play
what just seemed slightly better but I
think somewhere around this stage
certainly an under could have improved
somewhere i'm not i'm not one hundred
percent so sold on which position
exactly what's clear is that he played
nine f6 book III and in this particular
position after luke t cell and a five we
see that there are some ideas for white
mostly before and then Knight c3 to a
four to be six this would be excellent
if why it accomplishes that the night
only two is not doing much and it would
be excellent on b6 attacking and
controlling important squares and then
you can even build up more pressure
again to the six pawn what's clears in
this position island played the move
Queen g5 after quite some some minutes
of thought and you could instantly see
that counsel was aware that okay
something's off here could you fly this
the strange move or a surprising move
enter he played if I threat to flee
quickly and it becomes apparent that
blakiston and an instant trouble here
you cannot take of course as this heaven
is just saying this is winning a
peaceful for nothing and if you cannot
take your night is attacked where are
you going black only has 98 and this
immediately looks very much wrong so we
just blundered into that and ya know 98
was played and here we we come to the
unique almost unique situation for the
whole match and this is because in this
position magnus carlsen is committing
the only real mistake he made in the
whole match to be honest I think he
drifted in some trouble in Game three
with some inaccurate rules and yesterday
okay on earth had an attack but nothing
totally clear
and you also couldn't say we made any
big mistakes but now he's really making
mistake are not blundered with Queen g5
and now with the right move on and
causal could basically win the game and
there's more than one actually but
somehow he overlooked I guess something
after the capture he took on d6 to tell
that and the relatively quickly but
after move like a Knight c3 where you
just keep the tension for a moment black
is completely out of moves he can never
take on e5 and white just improves the
position further this is completely lost
I mean really really Roxy 6 and then say
let's say b4 what is black going to do
we can never take you cannot play d5 he
cannot move the night it's basically a
yeah we see chef know me we can also he
also must reckon with 94 year let's say
something like that what what about that
yeah white is simply winning and 93 is
not difficult to spot for example the
the two commentating players at this
moment the national master trend and um
Indian known I am Tonya's lot chef they
both instantly said oh and 93 isn't this
winning and in fact night g3 is the same
thing about 93 I even like more so this
would have won the game simply but
Carlton took on d6 and after Luke c6
maybe he he miscalculated something it's
it's not clear um but now the thing is
okay you've wondered is six porn but how
are you going to keep it and the in fact
there is no way to keep it black world
will get the porn back and after the
further moves queen d8 all this black
gang
established material equality again and
they traded all this down to this night
and game and ok of course they are over
move 30 so they could just make a draw
here I mean Island I don't think would
have declined if Cal's an offer to draw
because well the practical winning
chances for black guy like zero but okay
this is not cause the study continues
and went on for a couple of moves white
first centralized thinking and black
also needs the King to defend the
queenside so on how to assess this
position yeah it's somewhere between
equal and very slight edge for wide
because why to suppress mezmur space d 4
against d7 the king is more active and
also potentially your three points
against two pawns might be good for for
a passed pawn in the near future but
it's not enough to really win the game
and we see that after the following
rules gather so very logical black
activating the night but after those
moves um why does intending after g3
this was hanging intending to enter with
the night on d6 and possibly attack f7
or window g7 porn so the question is
what should like do and i'll enter
played precisely i'm really precisely
plane f5 the only move to to continue
here's black otherwise you're in big
trouble for example if you if you go
here to attack g3 white just returns and
to look at the Schneider distract but
white will just approach the snide and
ask it where are you going so
not a good idea after that there's 96
and as mentioned this is the big problem
here also take into account at this
check allows this King to enter the
check is not only winning the pawn but
also driving the King away from the
defense of the b7 pond so only one move
f5 and correctly plate 96 and now okay
this is a threat and Allen place most
actively g5 and in fact i think the the
endgame here was later um yeah played
perfectly by both players g5 and now cos
activated the night trying to get to the
kingside ponds and all this was very
nicely played and now please ni 2g8
night h5 is an alternative and the
computer suggestion and it's typically
weird why why put tonight on h5 what is
it doing there but okay that is a point
of course white threatens King b6 and to
take the pawn and if black you a black
cannot really go back black needs to
attack the night trying to try to win it
and this is a very deep variation but
it's it's almost forced so we can we can
look at that and now the sea porn is
running but black of course has
counterplay we can now continue with the
taking and now I'm after the capture
black needs to immediately get the
airport going so this is the only way to
go takes and yeah like a sec we down at
the moon and white can check but there's
no way that why this is going to prevent
the swiftest Queenie and in fact this is
a draw there is not much not much going
on Queenie a check for example
is one way to to draw this at the end
check and this will end in a perpetual
check so a very long variation night h5
was an alternative but he plated
differently had played 98 and I think at
this moment he already had calculated
what was happening until the end of the
game like a tech tonight to go to Ghana
on age six and after this you see that
of course the night is trapped this is
what Magnus had calculated and I took on
f5 this is the important point as now
white gets the queenside pawns if black
takes with the night however after King
b6 he is even losing note that the
problem is that you don't have any
counter play with the f porn the point
is just here instead of f5 and after
this like immediately went for the earth
porn to have this counter play and all
this is very logical and and frost
almost so we had both sides queening and
whitis got three points for the night
but no worm chances whatsoever for both
sides I mean the position is even drawn
without the white pants and what cannot
really do much with his pawns so it's
very Jewish oh I just the draw Georgia
sir wrong word we had a couple of more
Muslim check check yeah entire check
after Queen c7 King h6 check white
played Queen B 6 and it's the small
magic it was clear that this game was
ending in a draw and they put out a
couple of more moves and Knight takes
each take c5 and that's it the game was
drawn here of course as both sides
any material left and yeah Island
congratulated calzon for some to his
match victory he won this championship
match with plus three score without
losing any game six and a half against
three and a half and yeah with this game
magnus carlsen becomes the 16th 16th
undisputed chess world champion going
back the whole line this is a big
heritage of chess from from steinitz in
the 19th century up to now modern skulls
and becoming the champion at 22 years of
age I think he's the second youngest
Kasparov was a couple of month younger
even and yet also it's the logical sort
of end of this this road Graham Carlton
has been the best player form already a
couple of years which seems really
strange given his young age but already
since about two thousand nine he has
been on top of them the rating list and
um he also entered this match being the
relatively clear favorite and in fact
them I had predicted before the match
that cars would win with the plus to
score it is a plus three score at the
end and yeah we could witness that
causal with this almost mistake free
play is super super tough opponent to
play in match play it looks like how I
how is ever going to lose a game very
difficult to imagine at the moment and
it also made clear that Anand while
still being an excellent player um was
not able to really set him the type of
problems that I guess he needs to be
presented with to to to to get in
trouble but to be honest at the mo
there isn't isn't a player can do that
only I think only like players like
kramnik and aronian if they absolutely
top-notch for shape they can endanger
cards but let's see we will have fun the
next World Championship match then with
cars being the defending champion um I
think even next year so it's not like
two years or more and we have the
candidates tournament in did march i
think march march or april 2014 and then
we'll see you will challenge cousin mike
lee a favorite for this tournament disc
ramnik and I'd really like to to see um
Kramnik playing a war Championship match
against cards have been longtime fan of
chronic and I think the current wave
that he's playing he really sharpened up
his game would be would make an
excellent make an excellent match but
even this this match to be a competitive
match crumbling needs to be in an
outstanding fashion and I'll sending
shape to to compete with with Carlton
yeah to sum up the match I don't think
it is it has been a very memorable match
we didn't have any any really great
games you need to be honest with that
that gal who played on excellently high
level this is not what I'm saying but we
didn't really have those kind of classic
games that you expect to be analyzed for
a very long time but this in fact also
applies for for many other world
championship matches and games where the
emphasis is clearly on the on the aspect
of chess as a competitive sport where
the wind is really the the thing that
that counts most if you look better and
back at for example some of those spiral
Karpov
a lot of these especially if you look at
the first match they were really a
complete snoozers so not it's not like
everything was better in former times so
um alright so let's wrap up this match
coverage I hope you enjoyed the videos I
produced for all 10 games and I'll hope
to be back soon I do of course the daily
Blitz videos this will be a comment or a
constant feature of this channel also
look forward to more content coming in
2014 I'll be able to devote much more
time to the channel and they're coming
in the next year and this also means
that there will be probably am more
content on a daily basis so if you want
you will have yeah much more chest from
my channel every day alright look
forward to that and how do you back soon
thanks for watching